24 hours on and these fires are still
burning in the foothills of the pindelli
mountains near athens
hundreds of firefighters battled the
blaze which has engulfed dozens of homes
as the wildfires continue to spread
thousands of people have been evacuated
while some refused to leave insisting on
taking matters into their own hands
we have been battling since last night
we saved it at the last minute the fire
engine does not have any more water and
the fire keeps reigniting
the whole house burned everything was
lost books cds piano clothes icons
photos files everything that a person
would have i am 53 so imagine at the
moment we are only with what you see
here
in the nearby town of rafi more than 3
500 people were evacuated as fires
spread quickly
costas has a house in the hills here
he left on tuesday
now he doesn't know if he will have a
home to return to it's a little bit
strange because we have the hope that
our home will survive
but
we should be a little bit cynical
because
we can't do anything so
officials here say that since the start
of the fire season on may 1st there have
been already nearly 2 500 wildfires
the main obstacle for firefighters not
the high temperatures but the strong
winds which keep changing direction
starting new fires more than 90 000
people have been evacuated so far from
areas near the capital and the hottest
part of the summer is still to come
this small quiet town of anthusa home to
a few thousand people has already
witnessed the wrath of the fires this
year
while these homes have been spared
across the valley the damage is clear
the athens fire chief says his crew's
priority is to safeguard human life
something they've managed to do so far
greece is asking other european nations
for help to get through the fire season
which officially lasts until the end of
october
dorsojabari al jazeera and tusa greece